so uh not anybody
okay right so next up we have donna
marshall
which will tell us about reducing
non-unique games to boolean
unique games thank you
um okay so this is joint work uh with
ronald dan from the weizmann institute
um so let me start
by saying that the the heart of this of
this
work is actually is a new testing
theorem
and it's a testing theorem for read
functions
functions that get real input and have
uh
little outputs um
and and it asks about the degree d part
of
such a function for for d you know think
of uh
constant d maybe equals one or two or
you know a thousand but there's some
constant degree um so so this is
so here's the theorem um
so we have a function so so here for
technical reasons it will be a function
of the sphere
um i denote the dimension by by k
[Music]
and assume that it has has a bonded tuna
and now i go and i and i um
pick a completely uniform hyperplane
i'm calling it h um now
what i can do is i can look at this this
function
uh the restriction of this function only
to the hyperplane
and i can ask okay what's the degree d
part
of this function okay so so i should say
uh
functions on the scale with with bonded
two norm
uh have you know what what we would call
a fourier analysis atmosphere it's
called
getting power uh analysis uh
so mission analysis for functions in rn
um but so right so you can define
so there is a sequence of polynomials uh
and
and the form you know for normal basis
and and they define kind of the degree
one two three and so on uh part of
any function uh so so this is well
defined you look at the function you ask
what's what's its part
of the grid mostly uh it's a polynomial
of the grid mostly
um so so this is kind of a local view of
the function you only consider what the
function is
on the restriction to a random
hyperplane age
um and you can also ask what's the
what's the global degree
the part of the function this is what's
written here
um and then you can restrict that
to the to the hypoplane h and what the
theorem says is that with very high
probability over the hypoplane
uh the the the local view
here is the same as the global view
restricted to h
and up to basically one over the
dimension
and and the the of some factors that
depend on d
that we we neglect uh because we think
of the observed constant
uh attend a quick question so the
hyperplane means there's something with
co-dimension one right
it's not a two-dimensional thing okay
yes
hyperplane is called dimension one um
okay um yeah and whenever anyone has any
questions just
just just ask okay so
um good so so let's let's talk about
this display
the first thing i want you to notice is
that we're talking about proximity of
functions
okay so these are these are polynomials
of degree at most d
right in in k plus one variables
right so so with there are many many
monomials
in in such a polynomial in such a
polynomial a
all those monomials have to be
similar right it's not just in in
classical
you know property testing um there is
one property some brilliant function
that you're trying to
get right and here it's actually many
many many
um functions that you're getting all of
them simultaneously close
right this is what it means those
functions are similar so this is an
extremely extremely strong notion
of of similarity
so this is the first point i should say
that when we talk about
low degree testing for functions over
finite
finite fields we do have a similar
notion
um the the the local part the the local
uh logarithmic polynomial is is the same
as the globally
low degree point restricted um however
other finite field uh logarithmic
functions
of degree polynomials uh forum and all
collecting code so two
two different polynomials are different
almost everywhere everywhere
and this is what drives those very
strong proximity results
this is not true for foreign functions
grid functions low degree read functions
are not
um not all clothing codes so so it's
quite surprising maybe
that you can get such a strong proximity
between
functions so that's the first point to
make
um second point to make about the the
quantitative results this is a tight
result right you can take a
function to be half space and and the
deviation will really be one over the
dimension
um so you couldn't hope for anything
better um
i should say uh with standout sort of
fourier analysis
right jagenbauer or whatever analysis
you can actually uh prove such a result
however you will bound
the the this squared and
then get one over k bound which which on
on the two norm it will give you just a
one over squared k
bound okay um so so it's
you know standard to get to get one over
squared k
1 over square root k for our needs would
have given absolutely nothing
um so the entire question here
was how can you get the tight one over
the dimension
instead of what um you would naturally
get uh which is one of those quote k
um just an intuition for the one of us
called k
right we're talking about hyperplanes
right so we lose one coordinate one
coordinate is like uh
um right if
the functions are normalized to have
to know one in
okay so so this is the the theorem we
pull
uh we prove it with um
an interesting technique um so so what
you can do
you can look at this uh this two norm
this
difference uh you can look at this kind
of variable you can look at its
um it's a second moment
and the second moment is a quadratic
form that is rotationally invariant
um and and as such uh
by schulz lamont from presentation
theory uh
it only depends on the spectrum of the
of the form right with respect to some
you know that so if free analysis um
and not on the on the function itself so
so what we end up doing
is consider a function that depends only
essentially on one variable
um and then what we have is a two
dimensional
problem we need to look at the this uh
vector that defines the the hyperplane
we need to look at the
the direction in which the function
actually changes and
and it becomes a two-dimensional uh
problem that
you know to bound the the second moment
okay so so this is the the testing
theorem
i'd be very happy to answer any
questions
about it
is something similar true in gaussian
space or
where where are you using the spherical
harmonics so
we want to use this uh schulz lemma
and as a result it's it's
will look it's convenient to walk over
the the sphere
um yeah you can
what we actually need in the in the
paper is a result on on
you know alkay rather than sk
but we have some some extra condition
that we can place on the function that
makes it look like a spell called
function
okay okay any any other questions
okay so so this is going to be like a
cherokee's gun
right so this is the the gun i'm placing
on the
on the table in the first act and
it will go back to it in the last act
well i'll show you kind of analysis and
this will take
an important place in it
uh so so right all you need to remember
for later um if you want to know the the
low degree part of a function um
to restrict it to a hypo plan it's
enough to only look at the function
restricted with the hyperplane and
compute
the green part there okay
good so this is the the testing
the main testing we'll have in this in
this talk
so so this talk is about is about um
an attempt to prove the unity games
conjecture
um and i should say upfront uh
we're not trying to prove the full
uniqueness conjecture we're only trying
to
prove the unique games conjecture for
boolean alphabets
um we will only fix the alphabet
with boolean i'm going to define on the
next slide exactly
what the problem is um
it's a very famous open problem whether
hardness of boolean unique games implies
the full unique games conjecture
uh this is known as the is a strong
prayer repetition
question there was a lot of research on
it there is a very famous
obstacle not very but there is there is
an obstacle a known obstacle
to get this uh recently the world two
works
i was involved with one of them that
that gave us some reason for optimism
so you can get strong prayer repetition
in in certain
settings there are ways to avoid the
known obstacle
uh but but this is all uh material for
for different talks so for this talk we
only care about this boolean
against conjecture um
okay and and the the starting point for
for this talk is is a paper that's
bashcode and i
uh wrote up for stock 2016.
so four years ago um
in which we suggested the reduction that
would
take you all the way from non-np
hardness results
to uh to hardness of
boolean unique games um
and and we suggested a reduction um
but we didn't suggest an analysis for
the reduction we didn't
know how to how to prove that reduction
was
sound um in fact there was a serious
problem with proving that that reduction
was sound there was some
component that seemed tangential to the
main idea but
but nevertheless necessary uh and and it
kind of
prevented us from proving um soundness
of that reduction
and i'll point it out as we as we see
the details
later um but
yeah so four years ago um we we did want
to get
uh to finally get a get an analysis for
this
uh for this um
for this such a reduction after i think
they took
two and a half years of thinking on on
how to
avoid that that component that you
couldn't live with and you couldn't live
without
um and and what we decided to do
it was was to be less less ambitious so
instead of trying to get a reduction all
the way from
something that is known to be np hard to
to julian uni games
let's start with something which that we
only wish
to be np hard it's it's very similar in
in many ways it has the same spirit the
same feel
problems as are known to be np hard but
but we don't have an empty house for it
um and let's just get a reduction from
that
to boolean uni games and indeed this is
what
what we achieved uh in this this new
work with
with n um so even after those two and a
half years it
took another year and a half to get this
testing theorem that i
told you about uh that that allowed us
to
to actually prove that such a reduction
works
um okay so so uh
there is this question of okay we only
showed the kind of a reduction in the
air
um really what we want is a reduction
all the way from an mp heart
problem to boolean unique games um
and and the point is um well
if you right this is a big gap to to
bridge
to prove hundreds of boolean unique
gains uh
and and the only way to do it is to do
it gradually
uh and this is a this was our first step
right four years ago
it wasn't even clear that those ideas
from the
the pill in the paper with subash or
really the right ones it wasn't clear
that the parameters work out you know it
wasn't clear how to get rid of this
component
um and and right
doing this reduction kind of made us you
know prove interesting feelings
and it made us figure out the right way
to look at this
understand how to analyze it to develop
techniques
um so in my opinion it was a very
useful step um
i want to point out that there is a
reduction analogous to this
reduction that we showed that goals
would go all the way from np hardness to
boolean uni games
um now right now that we have this proof
of concept we're actually optimistic
that we'll eventually uh be able to to
analyze that
too okay so so this is this is what this
this talk is about i'll be happy to
answer
any general questions now
donna's just confirming you haven't told
us about the testing
result yet right like the precise
testing will not tell you anything else
about the testing result
um i said i i the only thing i'll do is
i'll use it
okay i stated it before
i told you something about how it's full
and
and at the end of this talk i'm actually
going to use it
uh to prove hardness of of boolean uni
games assuming this wishful
empty hardness okay
sorry what was the testing result so you
must have missed it what was the testing
center
the testing result was this uh it's it's
a low degree testing theorem fully
functions
so it says that if you have been given
the function
then below the grid part you look at the
function the function
is defined over you know many dimensions
you look at the hypoplants of one less
dimension
you look at the low degree part on the
hypoplane versus the low degree part
globally it's restricted to the
hyperplane
the two are essentially the same okay
the local part
is the same as the restricted the global
part restricted
back to the hyperplane
right this is it's a very very strong
uh it's not property testing it's just
it's really testing the two functions
all similar
okay right but but this this uh theorem
is going to recur
um at the end of the talk and when
i use it okay and for now i want to talk
about uni games
right this is the this is the the
subject of this talk that how to pull
the new game's contribution
okay uh let me start with with
uh explicitly defining boolean unique
games
uh so this is the kind of
an extremely simple field extremely
simple program
the boolean variables x1 to xn right
each one gets a
plus or minus one and all the line
constraints on them
each constraint is either the two bits
are the same
all the two beats are different
okay um and
right so why is it called the unique
game so game maybe we'll talk about
games a bit later
but uniqueness the idea is that if a
constraint like x equal
x i equals x j holds and you know the
value of x i then you know the value of
x j
and also if a constraint like x i not
equal x j holds if you know the value of
x i you know the value of x j
right because it's boolean right so this
would be the opposite of that
okay so this is the uniqueness one
variable determines the the value of
another variable the other variable
in every constraint so here's here's the
problem
um i give you this this system of local
constraints
in this constraint satisfaction problem
and i ask you can you distinguish
whether one minus that a fraction of the
constraints can be satisfied or whether
only one minus say hundred fraction of
the constraint can be satisfied the
hundred is is
completely arbitrary it's really any any
constant that you want
okay another way to kind of the way that
algorithms people think about it which
which i find a very useful way um
suppose that i give you a system of
constraints like that
and i tell you one minus delta fraction
of the constraints can be satisfied
right almost all of the constraints can
be satisfied
can you satisfy for me only 1 minus 100
delta
function of the constraints except that
you need to be an efficient algorithm
okay you don't know what's the good
assignment fine call me an assignment
that does that's why
so this is that greatly okay
um let's have like a little ruler here
to
um to understand the
the context um so
so we know that we have a system where
one minus relative fraction of the
constraints can be satisfied
the best algorithm that that manages to
satisfy as many constraints
as as possible is basically this
goemon's williamson algorithm
that that satisfies one minus square
root delta
fraction of the constraint with with a
very specific constant here
okay so so if you know this one minus
delta
the best algorithm would satisfy about
one minus
we think that this is tight we don't
know of any other algorithm assuming the
unique games conjecture there is no
better efficient algorithm
p not equal to np and and we look
at a much harder problem the problem
where
uh we want you to satisfy one minus
hundred delta
uh a function of the constraints right
for small delta this is much larger
than one minus co delta uh we think that
definitely this won't not be possible
because we think this is the best
possible
not not so much um
and so so can you prove it can you prove
that that you won't be able to satisfy
that exactly how to satisfy one minus
hundred delta
constraints this is what i call the
boolean unit games conjecture for any
sufficient delta
it's it's np hard uh to distinguish
those two or given a system well this
much can be satisfied satisfying this
much
and just for reference the full unigames
conjecture if you want a gap
between one minus delta and epsilon um
right you're given a system one minus
then the fraction of the constraints can
be satisfied
you want to satisfy on the epsilon
function this is only possible
if you take a sufficiently large it it's
only possible that this is np hard
if you take a sufficiently large
alphabet
and you take other constraints that are
that are unique
in so this is the full unique games
conjecture
okay any any questions about
unigame the unique games conjecture of
the boolean version
of uni games conjecture
okay let's talk about
why why we care so much about the
uniqueness conjecture
um so so here is here is the
here is the importance of this
conjecture for decades and decades
algorithms people have been designing
approximation algorithms for
combinatorial
optimization problems by reducing them
to geometric problems
why because uh people have been using
linear programming and semi-definite
programming
and and this is essentially what they do
they take
you start with maybe a graph and you're
trying to optimize something
and then you end up um embedding
everything in a cal end and you have
those linear constraints on them
or some indefinite constraints on them
um and and you know you solve that and
from that you're able to recover
a pretty good approximation okay and
this was a
very successful uh paradigm
um if you wanted to solve max cut it
actually led to questions about
uh as a program which is a perimetry if
you wanted to approximate fastest cut it
actually led
to questions about embedding
in so so somehow
uh classical problems in computer
optimization led to classical problems
in in geometry
um and led to beautiful algorithms
and and what the uniqueness conjecture
well this comes
is is actually on the homeless side
um and well you ask yourself are those
so those are the best we know are those
really the best possible
assuming p not equal to np is it is
doing better than this
and behind and the unique games
conjecture says yes
uh at least for very wide families
problems
so for example um doing better than than
this algorithm for max cut
um assuming the only game's conjecture
is actually
is actually empty hard and and this also
this follows from from geometry
um so so there is this this
um very tight connection between
very surprising connection between
computer optimization
and and geomet geometry basically the
the problems
those discrete problems are essentially
equivalent to
the geometric problems in
and this was extended to every
any local constraint satisfaction
problem this was also extended
by you know covering problems and many
other problems
um right then you can get like that
uh how much results that we couldn't get
with the uni games conjecture we could
get how much results that we couldn't
get any other way
okay so that's the that's the short
pitch
or for white care about the indians
conjecture
again whenever anyone has any questions
to ask
okay so a few years ago
i guess when i'm around the time i moved
to
to ut austin um i realized the best way
to describe
what what happened with research on uni
games is to describe it as a
football game um football game between
team algorithms and
and team harness and and
so so let's uh team algorithms started
they're actually fantastic algorithms
for for for uni games very strong
algorithms
so as i said so uh when the alphabet q
here is the alphabet when the alphabet
is
is two we can satisfy one of the squad
delta fraction of the constraints
uh if you want to have large large gap
you need the alphabet to be
exponentially large in
one over delta um
if delta is too small so you know that
almost all the constraints that is
satisfied for very close to almost
everything
um right so delta is one over log n
again good approximation algorithms
um there are even more surprising
approximation algorithms so it turns out
that for random graphs or random
constraints so basically any anything
random that you inject into the the
input
um the problem becomes easy um
and and this is in short contrast what
we know about
other pcps about projection games that
mentioned later
uh well well the graph can be random
and right and the constraints can be
random and we still think that all those
problems are
hard um team algorithms made
more progress with this all black star
algorithm
uh that that solved unique games for in
very long time two to the end
to something that depends on delta right
so the important thing is that it's not
true to the end
for projection games um
we know that the right the right uh
power here is one
under plausible con assumptions the best
algorithm we have
we expect to be basically two to the n
um
and and know for unique games you can do
much better you could do two to the end
to them maybe one over a hundred
right so so uh
team algorithms looked like it was
winning it even had
a kind of attack um and this is this
laser
sum squares hierarchy of semi-definite
programming it was shown to generalize
each and every algorithm
that was considered beforehand and and
researchers
in that area seem to think that maybe it
will get you all the way to this probing
during against conjecture
okay how about team harness so team
harness didn't do
very well um
so we have various techniques
methodologies improving hardness
of approximation and what they could
give
is that it's empty hard uh given a
system of one minus the
fraction of the constraints can this can
be satisfied it's np how to do
one minus something very close to delta
maybe two delta
now is the best but but the constant
kind of kept improving
um but definitely not better than the
two delta
the best hardness that was known um
[Music]
if not much is known so if you know
that your delta is half right your data
is huge
so you only know that that half of the
constraints can be satisfied
then indeed this is a hard problem and
how much results were known
um somehow missed results
it will also harvest results for for
basic semi-definite programming for weak
hierarchies of semi-definite programming
but not for a cell
um a big progress for team hardness
uh was was a two to two to two theorem
um from a couple of years ago uh so this
showed that for this easier case of
delta equals half
so so you know that only half of the
constraints can be satisfied now satisfy
as much as you can
er so this p1 said it's going to be and
how to satisfy even epsilon production
um now if you noticed i
erased this plan of attack of team
algorithms
because uh this
this two to two theorem was a major
obstacle for
that for that attack um because all
if those plans of the algorithms people
would have worked out
they should have also been able to prove
an algorith
get an approximation algorithm in the
case of delta equals half
and and small epsilon uh and they
couldn't do it
uh right and they won't be able to do it
because this is np hard
um so so at least with with
current with with the the ideas that the
algorithms people had
um those those are ruled out by this two
to two theorem
um okay and i should say we to have
this this uh plan of attack this is this
candidate our unique game that that i
i mentioned before um right basically
this
idea that we booked out for stock 2016.
okay so so this basically on
one or two slides is the entire work
that was done on uniqueness
i'd be very happy to answer any
questions about it
okay good so so hopefully
by now we established that uniforms
conjecture is
is an important problem and
and that it's not resolved yet um
and and now i finally want to you know
start talking to you about
about our reduction
and to do this i need to tell you what's
what's known in in pcb theorems right so
so i told you that we'll have we'll
prove how nice of uni games
assuming this wishful pcp theorem so
let's talk
first about what what is actually known
pcp
what are known pcp theorems and this
will also
give me a chance to explain this
connection to
games what's known as two football games
okay so so i want to define for you this
this object called a
projection game this was this is the
predecessor of uni games this is what uh
motivated the definition of unique games
the the
current uh optimal hardness of
approximation results we do know how to
prove or proved
assuming hardness of projection games
okay so so what's a projection game
so there are two players two provers uh
player a and player b
and there is a very fire between them
those two players
uh they can agree ahead of time on the
strategy
but but but then they can't once the
game starts they can't talk anymore
and developer goes and it picks some um
randomness and it uses the randomness to
ask questions
to player a and player b and those
questions are usually correlated
questions right those questions can be
something like here we have some you
know some some
frisat instance
a player hey here all these and these
and these
variables can you give me the the
assignments for them and tell b
he all these and these and these
variables can you give me the
answers for that okay and then tell a
uh responds with its answers so maybe
those assignments
to those variables and they'll be
responds with
with its assignments and and the
verifier organizes it
so so the two questions are going to
have a large overlap
right so so the question to a will have
some subset of vertices
of variables and the question to be will
have an intersecting
subset of variables so so there will be
a way
right so the questions are correlated
and there is a way to to test
the two questions the two answers
against each other
because here i denoted the intersection
by this this light blue
um and maybe these are the variables
that the two
the two questions had in common and and
the valley file is going to check
that indeed they give the same
assignments to those common variables
okay so delta usually it checks
something
on the you ver you question
separately um right maybe those
variables also span various constraints
so it's going to check all the
constraints that those variables span
it's also going to check all the
constraints that are spent by by
those v variables and it will compare
the
the answers that uh that
in the intersection that the two
questions have in common
okay so this is this is what's known as
a projection game why is it projection
the projection is like this this light
blue part
right in the end what we do is we check
the projection of the two question of
the two answers uh to the intersection
okay uh and then the kind of the
strongest pcp theorem we have
is the following so so we defined the
value of again
as assuming that the players pick the
best strategy for them
what's the probability that the very
file accepts right and vertical accepts
if
the answers of new separately will find
themselves on v for separately were fine
and they agreed on the intersection so
what what's the probability that this
happens
and this super strong pcp theorem
started what what all the the known
optimal inapproximate results are
based off is is the following for any
epsilon larger than zero it's np how to
distinguish value one
from value epsilon so even if there
exists a strategy for the players
uh that makes the verifier always accept
so this is value one
even then if you are an efficient
algorithm you won't be able
to find a strategy that achieves value
larger than
epsilon okay this is a super super
strong theorem
okay as always if there are questions do
let me know
um i should say that various variants on
this still am unknown
so for example um you can ask
those underlying supposed the underlying
constraints on u and v
would be linear right so really um
there are some linear subspace linear
constraints
on on this vector linear constraints on
this vector
um and these are this is what developed
yet in addition to checking to comparing
um and and even then it's still known
this gap which is basically gap one
between completeness and soundness uh
the gap
the completeness now has to be one minus
delta
uh because if everything if all the
constraints are linear
it's always possible to find an
assignment that satisfies everything
right because it just causes an
elimination
um so you have you to introduce some
some completeness error
but it turns out that the completeness
error can be arbitrarily small
delta and and you'll still be able to
show this big
gap uh is np hard okay so even though
there is a strategy for the players
where that they win with probability one
minus delta
the efficient algorithm won't be able to
find a strategy that even
satisfies that even wins epsilon options
okay let me tell you about another
result so so this is a result that that
subhash and i
proved this was stock 2011. this was
actually in the
when we first started walking on this uh
direction to
to uh uh pulling the uniqueness
conjecture and this we we figured out
that we need something like that
um so so standard pcp theorem
everything is usually over let's say the
boolean hypercube
okay so everything is usually is a
boolean or or maybe a finite field or
something like that
um it turns out that you can do
everything over the wheels
right so so the the answer u this vector
is going to be a real
uh vector the answer v here is going to
be a real vector
um there are some going to be some real
uh
linear constraints on u we really don't
know constraints on v
and the thing about that is is that then
it makes sense when you compare the
intersection
it makes sense not only to accept when
the intersection is exactly the same
but to accept also when the intersection
is quite similar
uh and what we showed is that even if
you count
a similar intersection like and two norm
uh as as this is fine for
the algorithm even this is going to be
hard uh
for the algorithm okay so so
um even if you allow on those on those
common
common indices to have uh to have
well this is just ui minus vi to have a
distance square delta even then
it's going to be and be hard to achieve
to achieve value
you know a constant a large constant
value um
okay so this is what we call robust
we call it robust linear equations over
the the reals
uh in other words um right so if you
if you're trying to solve the real
real linear equations it makes sense to
do something like
um like um
how is it called mean squares
um right which would give you you
wouldn't have exact satisfaction that
the linear constraints would not be
exactly satisfied you will be
close to being satisfied um
and and and we show that this as best
possible
okay even if you allow this this
approximate
agreement on the intersection even then
the algorithm cannot cannot do much very
well
okay questions about this
this is the version that that is most
relevant
to what i'll talk about next
uh so i have a question is there
qualitative sense in which
uh this result was reals is like
better than what is known over finite
fields
like i mean because he still sees the
same route
qualitative or quantitative
yeah yeah okay so let me let me
emphasize it in when you talk about
discrete these quickly in our equations
the only thing the only measure of how
successful
an assignment is is to ask whether the
equation is satisfied whether you know
those two things are supposed to be
equal are they equal or not equal
there's no sense in which you can be a
little equal
right either it's equal or not equal i
guess you can ask
on how many indexes are equal but i mean
it's either either you have equality or
you don't have equality
when you talk about real assignments
you can ask how close they are to being
the same
right right you can ask you i minus vi
um right which is which is
right and and then to to say that you
can't even
um that they can't even be close right
it's much much stronger
qualitatively in
sense than than than it is to just say
that it's not satisfied
exactly um
so it's it's a very it's a it's a big
it's a much
harder theorem qualitatively um
right we use all the standard things
that are used
all the time but we also need to
robustness which which was
quite difficult um now
you asked about the quantitative aspect
the square delta i should have said that
this quote that is exactly the right
thing you would hope here right assuming
that there is a strategy
well there is one minus delta
uh with probability one minus delta they
agree exactly
uh kind of this mean squares algorithm
which is basically semi-definite
programming algorithm would would give
you a deviation of square root delta
why because because what it would do is
we it will look at the
it will minimize the squares it will
minimize the
the the the l2 square
and and then to square in the
completeness case would be delta
um and so in the soundest case the the
all you can hope for
um is is also delta but but this is a l
to square it so if you go and
look at l2 it's squared
okay so so this is the square delta is
is exactly tight it shows that the
semi-definite programming
is is tight uh for for this problem
um okay
and it's exactly the the scroll delta
here
is the same scroll data that you see
throughout this talk it's always the
same
the same issue but what efficient
algorithms can do
is is optimized in n2 squared
and if they optimize in l2 squared then
what you can say about the l2 difference
is you know you'll have this square root
um and and this is the entire question
of of boolean how does boolean unique
games
whether you can do better or you can do
better
okay i hope that this answered yes
thanks yeah thanks happy to answer other
questions
so here is here's the shortcut
that we allow ourselves in in this work
um so in this projection game setup
in the situation oh and i should say
also we can we can make sure that the
the intersection can be very very large
i mean maybe you'll you'll pay here in
the gap
for this large intersection but um
the intersection would be very large and
we still have and be almost like all
um okay
um now now in this
in all those discrete well all those tcp
theorems that we're able to pull
what happens that um the player knows
that the the you know the projection the
intersection well it's going to be asked
is in a subspace that is uh parallel to
the axis right it's it's on coordinates
uh so this spell a has all those
coordinates it needs to give it has all
this vector that it needs to give
and it knows that it's going to be
compared on some of those coordinates
okay but it's definitely going to be
compelling coordinates
um and the shortcut that we give
ourselves the reason it's only a wishful
uh pcp theorem rather than a pcp problem
we can give
is that we're going to define this
variant of projection games
while the intersections between those
two vectors are not
on coordinates but on general hybrid
planes
okay so let me let me define it exactly
so this is what
what i call what we call the subspaces
near intersection game so again there
are two players player a and player b
um each one gets linear a linear sub
space in in
rk out to the k um
linear subservice this is what this what
is what represents the
it represents the the constraints that
we have on on the vector the linear
constraint
uh and then there is some hyperplane
that the verifier
has in mind it's a specific hyper plane
and it's not telling anyone the
hyperplane right and this is what
corresponds to the to the intersection
coordinates that we had before
and now um each player is supposed to
answer with a unit vector
in its subspace as in a unit vector that
satisfies the linear constraints
it knows about and what the valid file
is going to do
is accept it's going to um check the
projection on the hypoplane
of each vector and it's going to check
whether the projections are the same
okay so this is subspaces near
intersection
uh right so subspaces because we have
you know subspaces near intersection
because we don't check
that the two vectors are the same they
have to
agree on a hyperplane okay so so this is
the game this is the projection game
we would want to work with um
okay oh i should say another comment
uh so so i i'm talking here about
objects that live
in space so what do i mean obviously
um how do we represent the
uh so so what i mean
is that uh uh we choose some precision
position is much much higher than any
other quantity we care about all those
deltas and whatever and
and we represent numbers real numbers
only up to that position
okay and then of course there are going
to be precision errors everywhere
but but they're not very they're
inconsequential so so
i'm going to ignore them okay but this
is what i mean right real
the numbers are represented up to some
very very very large precision
okay and this is the game uh
so here is here is what one can do with
semi-definite programming suppose that
there exists a strategy for the players
that is accepted with probability one
minus delta as in the projections are
exactly the same with probability one
minus delta
what can you guarantee efficiently if
you write the semi-definite program
what you can guarantee is that the
projections the
the l2 squared um
distance between them is at most delta
which corresponds to
the l2 difference is is square root
of delta okay so so why is this because
um the the the fact that there exists a
strategy that is accepted with
probability 1 minus delta
means that with 41 minus delta the two
things are going to be zero
so this would be zero and then what we
delta those two things
can be maybe one right because it's unit
vectors
um so so i get i get this bound of
delta on the l2 squared um
from the completeness case and so we
expect the same
in in the in the soundness case in
and right
and this would guarantee l2 difference
which is quote delta with
and i can guarantee it with high
probability and and
with some constant here okay so this is
what sdp can do
for for this game and
this this wishful pcp theorem our
conjecture is that this is going to be
the best possible
and for for this game
and and if you believe that this is best
possible for
for the game then we can prove boolean
hundreds of boolean union games
are there any questions about about
subspaces near intel section
and hardness
in hardness assumption
okay so so this is the main result
hundreds of subspaces near intersection
implies the boolean unique games
conjecture
um okay so so
let me tell you about the methodology
how to improve hardness
how much of approximation results in
general right ever since
you know the 90s um
so right so we have this projection game
well there are questions
to the players and there are answers and
there is this specification
and the methodology says
what we're going to do is consider an
encoding
of of those of those answers
and usually right it's a boolean
encoding usually via code that is called
the long code
um and you should think of our new
variables
as as those as those uh bits
in the encoding so you have those
variables and those variables for all
possible questions
uh to the players these are going to be
you know
variables it's in the unique game or
whatever you're trying to prove how much
of approximation for
and what you do is try to simulate
the the the test that the verifier wants
to do
which is maybe the test here or test
here
um and you will simulate it
by the unique tests uh on those boolean
variables here okay so this is the
general methodology for for proving
optimal hardness of approximation it's a
very
successful methodology um
in general right to prove various sounds
approximation results
right you just encode and you try to
simulate the verifier
using those those bit
constraints on the beats and
and this is what we'll try to do here
too
except um right so first of all we'll
start with the subspaces near
intersection game
right well we have these
and except that we'll use a very
untraditional
encoding scheme um which which is
encoding by by a half space and and what
do i
mean by that um the this player is
supposed to answer
some vector right and this player is
supposed to have until some vector the
the encoding of the vector well thinking
of this vector
as um defining a normal defining a
half space and here
we write the the truth table of this
of this half space this tip
i see a question um
question okay um
yes so yeah it was a reminder that i
should
finish in 10 minutes which i i will sort
of do
um the idea of encoding
answers with half spaces was this was
the major
idea uh in the paper with with
subash on on how to prove hundreds of
union games
right instead of using the loan code
other calls that are used here
just encode a vector with the half space
that the vector defines again right this
is overall
and we do everything up to a precision
okay
why is this good because we can do
various
various tests maybe let me not
um
the the main test that we're going to do
uh uh
two um uh
we're going to check um we're going to
do a noise test uh what what's a noise
test so so
what's special about half spaces why do
we want to encode these half spaces
um half spaces are known to be
the solution to the isoparametric
problem in gaussian space
and if you look if you do this
noise test well you take a a random
gaussian point in rn and then you
perturb the point a little
um you you shift it along a random
direction with give it a small weight
and you ask whether it change the
function with the unchanged function
um so this is the noise test it's it's
important
is that it's one of the only tests that
we can do
if we have a boolean unique games right
because it checks equality
between bits okay there are very few
things you can do with the quality
between two bits but the noise test is
is one of them
and and half spaces are the functions
that maximize the acceptance probability
of of the noise test okay this is this
is
why we picked this half space encoding
the other thing you can do
is um you can check that those two
functions
actually agree on the hyperplane
um right that if if they're supposed to
be the same on the hyperplane then then
you can test it this is again something
that you can do with unique tests
and the other thing you can do is is do
various
linearity tests uh on on this
on this function but this is it this is
this is the entire
hard boolean unique
okay
questions
okay and
so this is my last slide i'm going to
outline
the entire analysis of of this
uh unique game
and right on one slide i'm going to use
the testing theorem
that i mentioned in the very beginning
okay and they're going to be four steps
to the analysis and all of them are
quite uh
natural so so here is here's what we do
um okay so so first of all we have we
have this consistency test where we
we check the two functions on the
hyperplane
um and those are two uh
uh right those those functions that we
talked about our
boolean functions right they're supposed
to be half spaces right these are
boolean functions
um and and we know that our very typical
typical answers um are
the same uh using hyper contractivity
sorry we can show that the low degree
parts right we picked
some degree which is which is a
sufficiently large constant the low
degree parts
um are going to be
close in into a difference
uh up to delta so this is the first
step this is what we use the consistency
on hyperplanes
and now we finally use the testing
theorem and
as i told you the testing theorem is
basically works smoothly on
the sphere and we we want to walk in gas
in space and we have this trick to
basically move to the sphere right
forget that
and the the the main issue is that the
the degree d
um the greedy part of the function
is the same right we can um we can put
the degree d
uh inside right so so it doesn't matter
whether
what you do is you take the the actual
degree d and then you restrict it to the
hyperplane whether you take the
function restricted to the hyperplane
and then um
and then consider the degree d this is
the same
essentially the same um
now we need to use the noise test right
notice that the entire
like a boolean how the uni game it has
basically
two or three tests that you do right
it's basically consistency and noise and
maybe some
testing uh linear constraints
so here we use the noise test because
the function is
is noise stable we know that it has a
substantial
low degree part um right for
um say 0.9 for
some loud constant um
so so here is here's what happens so
question of the to the prover what we
what we have is uh the degree d
part of this function and we know that
those degree deep parts of the function
are consistent because of what we just
pulled
um so they're consistent on the
hyperplane
right which is almost almost what we
wanted
except that what we really wanted is a
unit vector per question
rather than a degree d part so
one of the majority of the analysis uh
now is just
to show that from uh degree d
parts you can actually get um unit
vectors
that are similar and we do that just by
differentiating the
[Music]
the the the greedy part something like d
times
until we we get unit vectors
but this is it right this is the the
entire outline of the
analysis um
i think that they even have two minutes
to spare if anyone
has has questions
thank you donna are there any questions
actually okay i mean in the media i have
a question is there like a succinct way
to say why like one over k was critical
or why something greater than one over
root k was necessary for your analysis
like is it like a simple like is it
like is it possible to see at this level
of description is it much more intricate
yeah i i i
you know you need to look at yourself
a lot of feedback i don't know why this
this seems a lot of
all right so this should be better yeah
right
um yeah so so
this problem
makes sense right
um you don't want
right if you picked k to be very large
um right what happens
is that the the this problem becomes
very similar to it basically becomes
unique games
right because it um
the the the you you expect a one overs
quote k
uh uh difference between between the
projections
okay just just the the provers cannot do
anything can
do almost nothing and still get one of
us called k getting one of us called k
difference is is is not interesting
right this is only interesting when when
k is is about something like one over
delta or something like that
um well well one of us called k's
is large whereas to get the delta
difference is
is small um so so we don't want to lose
one of those code k
this would give you um
it will kind of
not make it an interesting problem
are there other questions
uh well that doesn't don't doesn't seem
to be any other questions
well uh in that case thank you donna and
we will resume in uh a little less than
15 minutes
uh at uh well 3 45 eastern time with
next episode so we'll resume in ten 10 3
actually 45
and 10 15 10 to 15 minutes